[Music]
on this monday night new measures to
slow the spread of omicron
manitoba and new brunswick impose new
restrictions we are once again urging
manitobans to limit your closed contacts
as canada grapples with surging
infections
weather warnings grip western canada
millions of canadians caught in a
dangerous deep freeze as the u.s west
coast digs out from a disruptive winter
storm we were supposed to leave this
morning flight got cancelled so we're
making the best of it award-winning
filmmaker jean-marc valli dies at 58 how
the industry is remembering the
acclaimed montreal-born director
and from supply chain woes to the rogers
family feud the top business stories of
2021
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight colleen christie
evening thanks for joining us we begin
with a rapid spread of omicron and new
measures to try to slow it down with
case number spiking tonight new
restrictions will take effect in new
brunswick and manitoba in manitoba there
are new capacity limits for public
gatherings liquor sales will stop at 10
pm
we know we can't
rely on some of the reports of omicron
being
less severe we know with the amount of
transmission we're seeing we're going to
see that demand translating into
increased demand on the health care
system
today canada officially surpassed 2
million coveted infections with cases
surging like never before hospitals are
bracing for potential impact abigail
beeman has tonight's top story on the
response
and i thought it was a unique experience
to come to a strip club for a
vaccine toronto strip club turned low
barrier booster hub we have a lot of sex
workers accessing our clinic as a sex
worker justice organization but also
poor working class folks without
documentation as ontario reports another
9 400 new cases they're probably a gross
under count across the country with
testing capacity stretched experts say
the true count is likely far higher
manitoba and nova scotia the latest to
change tax monday nova scotia limiting
access to pcr tests with rapid tests
also in finite supply you shouldn't
really just assume that next week if the
numbers of cases reported go down that
omicron is gone while most agree the
important indicators are not case counts
but hospitalization and icu numbers
there are outstanding questions for
those who don't get tested or who rely
on rapid test results which are not part
of the official tally this creates a lot
of other logistical challenges in terms
of for example like how do you document
for example that you have had covet
there's an optimism that's starting to
break through and we're seeing it in all
the specialties radiologist david jacobs
tweeted positive news from the front
lines while his toronto er is busy
omicron patients overall are less sick
the virus is attacking the upper airways
but not making it into the lungs as it
has in the past it's not making it into
the lungs in vaccinated patients
in quebec hospitalization numbers are
climbing the premier urging people to
get boosted as he gets his we have to
protect our hospitals
but it's a crawl to get there as of
monday only those aged 60 plus are
eligible abigail beeman global news
ottawa
in israel a trial has begun to see if a
fourth dose of covet vaccine can help
protect vulnerable people against the
virus it comes as the vast majority of
people in africa are still waiting for
their first dose one of the countries
with the lowest vaccination rates is the
democratic republic of congo redmond
shannon reports on the situation there
each wave of covert 19 in the democratic
republic of congo sees higher infection
numbers than the last since mid-december
numbers have skyrocketed likely fueled
by the omicron variant
the head of one treatment center says
over six days admissions increased
six-fold the official infection rate is
still far below that of rich nations but
that is likely due to limited testing
the country has the second lowest
vaccination rate in the world almost 82
percent of canadians have had at least
one dose of a coveted vaccine most of
those people have had two in dr congo
less than one third of one percent of
people have received at least one shot
advocates for vaccine equity say
variants like omicron will continue to
appear as long as the virus spreads
among unvaccinated populations i think
as canadians we need to think about why
we're getting this third dose and it's a
result of vaccine hoarding and it's a
result of canada securing millions of
excess doses ananya banerjee says canada
and others must prioritize vaccine
donations and temporarily waive vaccine
patents until then she says new variants
will keep on coming if the rich world
simply tries to boost its way out of the
pandemic
back in kinshasa government mistrust and
vaccine hesitancy remain an issue
but residents like this man say they've
now seen the effect of covert during
this wave and they need vaccines to
protect themselves from it redmond
shannon global news
here in canada much of the western part
of the country has descended into a
dangerous deep freeze extreme cold
weather warnings are in place across
alberta british columbia saskatchewan
and parts of manitoba edmonton and
calgary are dealing with wind chills
ranging between -40 and minus 55 celsius
it's a similar situation in the u.s with
several western states hit with winter
storms the storms knocked out power for
thousands of people and disrupted
traffic on the roads and in the air
jennifer johnson reports
in reno nevada whiteout conditions led
to a 20-car pileup
search crews were sent out to rescue
people stranded in their cars in
california's sierra mountains
in seattle snow and ice grounded nearly
a third of the flights we were supposed
to leave this morning flight got
canceled so we're making the best of it
even sunny southern california saw the
white stuff come down a first for many
residents where he came out here to
enjoy some snow it's actually their
first time being in the snow
the national weather service issued
winter storm warnings from the canadian
to the mexican border a 112 kilometer
stretch of interstate 80 along the
nevada california state line was closed
due to dangerous conditions bad timing
during this busy travel week we're happy
there's snow but then again
there's no business but climate experts
say this is a real christmas present for
california which suffered its worst
drought conditions this past year than
in nearly a century the more rain and
snow we can get the better
and because we have a huge deficit and
the longer it can stay cold in the
winter the better for keeping that snow
frozen
snowy conditions are predicted from the
sierra nevadas to the colorado rockies
through tuesday making skiers really
happy even those who decided to try out
their equipment on neighborhood roads
jennifer johnson global news washington
a country in mourning coming up how
south africans are marking the passing
of archbishop desmond tutu
[Music]
in cape town south africa church bells
will ring out at noon each day until
desmond tutu's funeral mass january 1st
a week of mourning has begun with
tributes to the archbishop pouring in
from around the world tutu won the nobel
peace prize for his racial justice work
that helped end apartheid he died sunday
at the age of 90.
women in afghanistan face another
roadblock as the taliban tightens its
grip officials say afghan women
traveling more than 72 kilometers by
vehicle must have a male companion the
directive calls on drivers to refuse
rides to women without islamic head
scarves this is the latest of many
taliban imposed restrictions placed on
women despite promises of a less strict
regime
from boardroom drama to the supply chain
crisis ahead we recap the top business
stories of 2021.
you're watching global national
with the new year just around the corner
tonight we are looking back at the top
business stories of 2021. it was a busy
year with no shortage of drama from a
family feud at canada's largest telecom
firm to supply chain disruptions and
surging real estate prices here's ann
gaviola
we had more time on our hands and some
of us with more cash easier access to
stock trading platforms and social media
so the meme stock frenzy became the
culmination of many covetera trends
stocks like gamestop and amc became
household names overnight as investors
many of them knew bought into the drama
pitting day traders against storied
hedge funds a modern-day robin hood tale
according to this financial writer i
felt like it had a sports fan feel you
know the people who were getting
involved were uh you know we're all part
of something bigger yeah they were
cheering
as inflation climbed month after month
after being tamed for so long the rising
cost of living made headlines too i just
feel
really bad for people that are
you know just can't afford to eat and or
pay you know rent and eat they'll just
have to make choices between
other other things that they do so no
entertainment you know no going out
um you know
sacrificing gas food housing it all
began to cost noticeably more and things
were in short supply too thanks to a
perfect storm of supply chain hiccups
creating a once-in-a-lifetime headache
for retailers there weren't enough
microchips rental cars shipping
containers or workers to meet surging
demand as economies reopened
inflated home prices were a feature in
2021 real estate companies say it built
on momentum from a massive surge of
interest in bigger houses and more
living space in 2020. a supercharged
focus on the importance of where they
lived because it had become their kids
school their workplace of work in
addition to their restaurant and their
their gym and everything and low
mortgage rates fueled the frenzy i'm
confident in the future of tesla elon
musk was everywhere too his space race
against jeff bezos tesla accepting
bitcoin and dogecoin as payment his
tweets his eye-popping u.s tax bill and
his selection as time magazine's person
of the year
and there was the rogers family
boardroom battle which hit home for so
many according to finance expert rubina
ahmed hawk it's a company that people
recognize it's a service that everybody
uses in some way even if they don't use
rogers services they definitely have
cable or tv services or cell phone
services that they use with
larger-than-life characters like martha
the daughter of founder ted rogers
tweeting about the real-life soap opera
as control of a media empire hung in the
balance i want to see what other news
operations we can sweep up and it bore a
striking resemblance to the family drama
in the hit show succession now
ultimately edward rogers won the legal
battle but the jury's still out on who
won in the court of public opinion ann
gaviola global news toronto
an acclaimed director is among those
lost this year our 2021 in memoriam next
an award-winning canadian director has
died according to his publicist
montreal's jean-marc valli died
unexpectedly over the weekend at his
cabin near quebec city the acclaimed
dallas buyers club director won an emmy
for his work on the hbo series big
little lies he's being remembered for
his creativity and authenticity the
cause of the death is still unknown